tuve que detener el vídeo pasado porque
ya no tuve tiempo pero bueno estábamos
viendo sobre las pendientes y vemos que
la pendiente es igual a menos 4 sobre 3
lo cual quiere decir que la elevación es
menos 4 cuando el avance es 3 entonces
la elevación es menos 4 cuando el avance
es estrés y puedes seguir haciendo esto
seguirás cayendo sobre la misma línea
también pudiste verlo como la elevación
8 y avance de 6
ahora el 8 es el doble de 4 entonces
caería justo aquí después avanza 6 y acá
es otra vez sobre la línea así que da lo
mismo hacer cualquiera de los dos
siempre y cuando avance sobre sobre jay
sobre x caes en la línea y puedo seguir
haciendo lo mismo y vamos a caer sobre
la misma línea ahora lo que nos quedamos
en esto en la ecuación de la recta
queremos saber cuánto vale y para saber
eso vamos a sustituir una o una x
con los valores que ya conocemos
entonces tomemos a este primer valor 2 -
3 y veamos qué pasa así que y es igual a
menos 3 voy a sustituir aquí tenemos
menos 3 menos 3 es igual a menos 4 sobre
3 por x y x es 2 más b entonces esto es
igual a menos 3 igual a menos 8 sobre 3
más ve entonces b es igual a aquí es
menos 9 sobre 3 menos 9 sobre 3 más 8
sobre 3 lo cual será igual esto es igual
a menos un tercio y esa es la
intersección de ella así que la línea de
la ecuación de la línea es la siguiente
ye igual a menos 4 sobre 3 por equis y
la b es igual a menos un tercio entonces
yo voy a borrar eso en donde hecho se ve
un poco su silla la pantalla pero ok a
esta vamos a graficar esto entonces
aquí aquí la intersección con el eje de
la siesta es en este punto en este punto
aquí está menos un tercio y sabemos que
ese punto es igual a cero coma menos un
tercio y tiene sentido esto porque ok a
supongamos que la equis vale cero
entonces esto esto ya no existe y así ya
sería igual a menos un tercio entonces
entonces tiene sentido esto es cierto
hagamos un ejemplo más para dejar en
claro ok entonces borro esto y parece
que no tengo otras cosas que hacer
cierto solo aburrirte espero no estarte
aburriendo estoy haciendo esto para
ayudarte
espero ayudarte entonces aquí está otra
vez
el plano
el eje cartesiano como lo quiera llamar
me voy a inventar algunos algunos
puntos el menos 85 y el el 2 el 2,0 lo
puedo combinar este tantos números si no
se me ocurre ninguno el 0 será
interesante con el 0 entonces 20 vamos a
graficar esos puntos aquí
aquí sería 8 y 5 para arriba
ahí está ok este es el punto menos 85 y
ahora el punto sería 12 y ahí está el 20
entonces ahora voy a dibujar una línea
una línea que pase por los dos puntos lo
siento lo siento que se está eso fue
inaceptable pensé que estaba usando la
herramienta de línea
ahí está mejor lo siento
y bueno las líneas van por los siglos de
los siglos avanzan en ambas direcciones
entonces ahí está entonces bueno ya
tenemos aquí la línea y vamos a calcular
su pendiente el cambio de ye sobre el
cambio de equis otra vez estoy usando la
herramienta de línea entonces m es igual
a 5 - 0 y 1 de 250 sobre x 1 x 2 que es
menos 8 menos 2 lo cual es igual a 5
sobre menos 10 y esto es lo mismo que
menos un medio entonces puedes ver que
bajamos 1 bajamos 1 y avanzamos 2
bajamos 1 y avanzamos 2 o podemos bajar
todos y avanzamos 4 porque 2 sobre 4 es
lo mismo que un medio espero tenga
sentido eso entonces bueno ahí está la
pendiente de la línea de hecho lo
hicimos bastante rápido entonces la
ecuación es ya igual a menos un medio x
+ b pero quién es b vamos a sustituir un
punto el 20 suena interesante entonces
tenemos tenemos 0 es igual a menos un
medio que multiplicados más b así que 0
es igual a menos 1 más b por lo tanto b
es igual a uno sencillo cierto así que
ya tenemos que y es igual
al menos un medio por x más 1 ahora aquí
está la intersección con el eje de las
yes es el punto 0 1 como nos dice esto
entonces 0,1 está justo aquí podéis ver
que que si está sobre la línea así que
nuestras operaciones algebraicas son
correctas y hay felicidades y podemos
ver que la pendiente es menos un medio
cierto y tiene sentido porque por cada
por cada uno que bajas avanzas 2 y así
cae sobre la línea o por cada 2 que
avanzas bajas 1 y otra vez caes sobre la
línea la pendiente es menos un medio
puedes ver que la pendiente es negativa
va de de arriba hacia abajo de izquierda
a derecha entonces bueno yo creo que ya
estás listo para hacer ejercicios de
pendientes así que diviértete y nos
vemos